because me monster tell us about thin
trees so hi everyone so this is so this
talk is about some combinatorial
conjecture about the existence of
something called increasing graphs and
I'm just giving this talk in this
workshop even though it's it's based on
a very old result I'm just giving it to
demonstrate the method for using
polynomials to go beyond things you can
do using randomized round so so let me
actually give you a brief introduction I
know that we've we've gone over this in
the bootcamp but let me just give you a
brief introduction on the rough ideas in
the method of interlacing families and
so the way I think of interlacing
families is as some sort of a
generalization of the methods of
conditional expectations okay so so this
is like the the most this is one of the
most used facts throughout I guess
mathematics that if you have a
collection of things then there is
always one of so if you have a
collection of numbers there always
exists a number that's smaller than the
expectation right but here is maybe a
little bit more advanced version of this
fact if you have a collection of
fractions then there always exists a
fraction which is so these are positive
numbers both in the numerator and the
denominator there always exists a
fraction which is smaller than the
expectation of the numerators divided by
the expectation of the denominators so
both of these are true and if you want
an algorithm that finds the the number
or the fraction promised by one of these
two facts if you're if you're dealing
with like an exponential family of
things what you can do is you can use
the method of conditional expectations
you can form a tree basically so in each
step you are basically partitioning your
your collection into two sets and then
just computing the expectation or the
expectation of the numerator divided by
the expectation of the now
denominators and then there always
exists a branch in the tree where this
expectation is getting war right so if
you start from the top
you can always Traverse down and then in
the Leafs you find the promise thing so
the method of interlacing families so so
you can you can basically see all of
these as as an instance of the method of
interlacing families okay so if you if
to each of the elements in your
collection you associate a degree one
polynomial so the BX minus a then this
power meal has route exactly a s over BS
right and and basically instead of
choosing instead of computing these
fractions and chasing them down the the
tree what you can do is you can look at
the look at these fractions as roots of
polynomials and then chase the roots
down the tree okay so the method of
interlacing families is basically a
generation of this whole idea two
polynomials of higher degree so if you
have a bunch of formulas and you're
taking their expectations as long as
some conditions are satisfied you can
again chase down the tree and find an
element in the leaves whose roots are
bounded by the roots at the at the top
so what Marcus Spillman and C Rostova so
when when they basically pioneered this
method one of the one of the key things
that they observed was that for this to
work for Paul miles of higher degree not
degree 1 and degree 0 you have to have
that the the the Paul meals in this tree
are real rooted that's pretty much the
only thing that you need for this to go
through and so as long as the Paul's all
at all of the nodes of this tree are
real rooted and as long as convex
combinations of siblings are also
reloaded then the whole thing is true
that that there always exists a leaf
whose
sir bounded by the rivets at the top so
so okay so we are gonna use basically
this this method to to to prove some
things about the combinatorial injector
so let me tell you about the
combinatorial conjecture
so the conjecture is very simple to
state you have a graph G what you want
to find is a tree which is thin with
respect to the graph what does thinness
mean thinness means that in every cut in
every way of partitioning the vertices
into two sides the tree must have at
most an alpha fraction of the edges in
the graph in the cut yes so you look at
the edges of the tree and edges of the
graph in the cut the tree edges must be
at most alpha fraction so that's just
the definition there is so so you could
you could look for something stronger
you could look for something called
aspect relief in tree so aspect relief
in tree is is is it's basically a
stronger guarantee it's a spectral
guarantee it's saying that if you look
at the laplacian of the tree and the
laplacian of the graph then the
laplacian of the tree is bounded by
alpha times the laplacian of the graph
right and just to make sure that
everyone is on the same page let me just
tell you what the Laplace hands are so
so if you have an edge in a graph a
laplacian of the edge is an N by n
matrix so this is n this is n which has
exactly four nonzero entries the rest of
the matrix is zero so this is the these
are the two endpoints of the edge e
and for a graph the laplacian is
basically the sum of the laplacian of
edges for all edges in the graph G so a
spectral fitness is a condition that's
stronger than the normal thinness and
this is because laplacian SCAP Chur the
values at the cuts so if you have
basically a cut then this is true the
end if you if you look at the quadratic
form given by the laplacian on the
vector the indicator of the set s this
gives you exactly the number of edges in
the cut
[Music]
so if you have spectral thinness then
that implies normal fitness
now so so the conjecture which I'm going
to talk about is about the existence of
these these thin trees okay and the
conjecture is is basically saying that
the obvious necessary condition is also
almost official okay so what's a
necessary condition for the existence of
a thin tree well if you are going to
have a tree which is let's say 1 over K
thin with respect to a graph G then it
better be the case that the graph G has
at least K edges in every cut right
because the tree is going to have at
least one edge in every cut so this
means that the graph must have at least
K edges in every cut if you're 1 over K
thin Gardens conjecture is that this is
basically sufficient up to a constant
factor
so all right so let me tell you a little
bit about the history of this conjecture
so so it's known that this conjecture
has strong implications for the
asymmetric traveling salesmen problem so
basically if you prove this conjecture
with a loss which can be a function of n
if you prove that KH connect being
connected implies f of n over K entries
exist then it implies that the the the
linear programming relaxation for the
asymmetric travelling salesman problem
is tied up to a factor of f of n now we
do now this is not that relevant anymore
because Swensen turn off ski and wag
showed that independent of the entries
this linear programming relaxation is
always tight up to a constant factor but
nevertheless their method by past
interest so the conjecture is still open
the conjecture and the existence of
taint resist or so so the first time
that you see you see this conjecture the
first method that you might try to use
is to basically look at what random
spanning trees look like right
so maybe randoms maybe you have
concentration phenomena and random
spanning trees satisfies some sort of
fitness with some loss maybe ok so
that's exactly what isaku commands Madri
and always Karen and so very did so so
let me tell you briefly about
what you can get using randomized
rounding so so KH connect having having
a K edge connected graph implies that
you can always choose a measure mu on
spanning trees
such that the probability that each edge
basically is selected in your collection
of spanning trees
is bounded by 1 over K okay so there
exists a measure on the spanning tree
such that this is true you can actually
take the measure to be basically the
uniform distribution on roughly K trees
there exist about about K edge disjoint
trees on on every such graph right so if
you have such a measure then the
expectation of the value of the cut is
good so in expectation your tree is
going to be thin right so so you have
this expectation is at most 1 over K
times the size of the cut now if you
have concentration of measure then maybe
you can expect that maybe for all such
cuts you wouldn't be too far from the
expectation so so turns out that you
have to you have to work with special
distributions because you can't hope for
concentration on every distribution so
there exists a very very special kind of
distribution so there exists basically a
lambda ease so this is a basically
there always exists a collection of edge
weights lambda e such that if you select
the tree with probability proportional
to the product of lambda is then so you
make sure that
so you can make sure that you you can
choose weights on the edges so that if
you select a spanning tree according to
the product of the weights on the edges
then you still have this condition that
the probability of each edge being
included in the tree is still bounded by
a 1 over K and then these measures are
sort of spread out so what they proved
was that for this the basically with
very high probability there exists or
the tree that you sample according to MU
is going to have at most log n over log
log n times value of the cut for every s
so we are going to work with this this
special distribution later on that's
what you get from just random spanning
trees so any questions so far
sorry yeah oh yeah
you recognize it's a good you recognize
if a tree is a good guy that's actually
a computationally we don't know how to
do it so if so if basically you had so
so if instead of checking whether a tree
is then you were checking whether a
general sub graph is thin then that
would be the generalized sparse cut
problem and we expect we can't we can't
solve it so yeah so so one of the so one
of the strange things about this problem
is that you can't check thinness but you
still want to construct something that
is there okay all right so so even
though you can't check thinness of
arbitrary objects you can still prove
that they exist so the randomized method
gives you log in over log log n so in
this talk I'm going to tell you how how
you can go beyond this randomized
construction and get log log or poly log
log and a working
so this is this is the the rough outline
so so goddess Guardians conjecture
wanted to go from some necessary
condition connectivity to the existence
of thing objects now if you if you look
at spectrally Thames trees you can make
sort of a conjecture on the spectral
side so I'm the spectral side something
which is necessary is is some some
spectral form of connectivity that I'm
going to talk a little bit more about so
so so for now you can think of it as
electrical connectivity which means that
think of basically your graph as a
network of unit resistances now if you
put basically a battery and on the two
sides on the two nodes of a net on the
two sides of an edge you can measure the
voltage and the current and if you
divide them you get the effective
resistance between this arrows so it
turns out that electric car electric
current is is some sort of a flow so so
so I'll get to that a little bit later
but basically the necessary condition
now becomes that the effective
resistance between any between the two
sides of every edge is bounded by 1 over
K this is actually a stronger condition
than K edge connectivity so so if you
have if you have the electrical
connectivity you also get edge
connectivity and then the equivalent
their spectral equivalents of thin trees
is just spectrally thin trees so you
want a tree whose laplacian is thin and
then you can ask whether or not the
spectral equivalent of Godin's
conjecture is true and that's a
statement that that follows from the
work of marcus Spielman service Toa and
and the follow-up of Harvey n over so
just to make make things clearer we want
to prove such a thing we don't know how
to and but we know how to prove the
spectral equivalent of guardians country
sure and it is it is really an
equivalent form because this is also
like the necess the obvious necessary
condition under spectral for you now you
can also always jump from the stronger
statement to the smaller to the to the
weaker statement if you if you prove
that a graph has spectrally thin trees
then you can also prove that they it has
thin trees but obviously you can't go
from the weaker assumption to the
stronger assumption so the main point of
this talk is how to go from this weaker
assumption to the stronger assumption by
relaxing some things
all right so so yeah so like I said the
vicar assumption doesn't imply the
stronger assumption here is an example
and so this is a this is basically a
large graph so you think of K parallel
paths on the top and K parallel paths on
the bottom and throughout the graph
there are K vertical edges going from
the top to the bottom so this graph is K
edge connected but if the distances
between these vertical edges are long it
is not K electrically connected roughly
the reason is that if you if you put a
battery on on the two sides of one of
these edges it would take a lot of
energy for the electrical food to to
good and use one of the other electrical
one of the other vertical edges
so so so if the distances are basically
long enough the the effective resistance
between the vertical edges between
endpoints of where the colleges is
almost 1 close to 1 now I told you that
electrical connectivity is actually a
necessary condition for their spectral
version so let me let me just quickly
tell you why so the effective resistance
you can for you can basically write it
down in terms of the laplacian of the
graph so for a graph there is this you
can form this
so you can so for every edge we you can
form this n-dimensional vector which is
one at at one endpoint of the edge and
minus one at the other endpoint of the
edge and now ve times the laplacian
pseudo inverse times this gives you
exactly the effective resistance eave it
respect to G so it is some quadratic
form of the inverse of the laplacian
evaluated at some point so if the
laplacian of the tree and the graph are
comparable if if the laplacian of the
tree is bounded by alpha times the
laplacian of the graph when you take the
inverses the laplacian of the tree
becomes one over alpha bigger than the
laplacian of the graph right so now when
you evaluate it at this particular
evaluate the quadratic forms at this
particular point you get an inequality
which tells you that the effective
resistance and the tree must be at most
must be at least one over alpha times
the effective resistance on the graph
right but the effective resistance of
any edge on the tree is exactly one so
so this tells you that the effective
resistance on the graph must be bounded
by alpha so that's a necessary condition
so this is the Siri condition we will
see later on that it's sufficient for
four days the existence of speculative
entries okay so but yeah but let me let
me let me focus now 4-under on the more
important issue which is how do you go
from the weaker assumption of KH
connectivity to the stronger assumption
of electrical KH connectivity so so the
idea the basic idea is that we can add
things to our graph to make it more
spectrally well conditioned so what does
that mean so assume that you have your
start from your graph G which is KH
connected and you add a bunch of edges
from from a graph on the same set of
nodes H and you make sure that the the
graph that you add is not too crazy
you're not blowing up the sizes of the
cuts so in every cut you want the graph
H to be at most doubling let's say the
number of edges but but let's say that
after doing this the your graph becomes
spectrally well-conditioned meaning that
the effective resistances are now
bounded by some alpha then you can use
then you can use the the spectral
version of guardian's conjecture and and
prove that there exists a spanning tree
in this h plus G which is spectrally
thin and then therefore it is thin with
respect to G Plus H
so so if you have something which is
thin with respect to G Plus H it is also
thin with respect to G right because we
didn't blow up the the cut sizes by at
most by more than a constant factor so
so if you have a tree here which is
bounded by in every cut bounded by alpha
times the value of the cut in G Plus H
this is also alpha times the value of
the cutting G now if you want to use
such a framework there are there are
obviously many problems so so the end
goal is to to to make sure that H brings
down the effective resistance is but one
of the obvious problems is that if you'd
bring down the effective resistances in
G Plus H how do you make sure the tree
that you find at the end doesn't use any
edge of H that's one obvious problem so
the other problem is you know I so going
back to to your question verifying
whether such an H is not flowing up the
sizes of the cuts is actually a
computationally hard problem right how
do we how do we deal with that okay so
so let me let me tell you how do we deal
with the first problem and that's making
sure that the newly ed and added edges
aren't picked so this is this is the
this is the statement I told you which
is the spectral equivalent of Gordon's
conjecture if you have a graph and it's
effective resistances are bounded by
alpha and then you have an alpha
spectrum you think it's right so if we
apply this to G Plus H we could the the
tree that we get could could be using
the newly added edges so instead we have
to prove something stronger so we have
to prove that if you have a special
subset of edges so this would be the
subset of edges from the original graph
F and if the effect
the resistance of the edges in f are
bounded by alpha and F itself is KH
connected then you can prove a thin tree
inside of f is the is the difference
between the two statements level clear
so the assumptions here are are
basically both weaker and stronger so
you so it's weaker in the in the sense
that for for the edges inside of f you
want the specter or the effective
resistance to be small but it's also
stronger in that you want F to be a KH
connected you don't want the whole graph
to be K H connected you don't just want
the whole graph to be caged
so so let me tell you a little bit about
why this is related to the method of
interlacing families is it okay to
so if you've seen carrion singer and the
method of introducing families before
you might be familiar with such a
statement that let's say these are the
laplacian of the edges that we have L 1
through LM so these are all Rank 1 PSD
matrices
so the condition that the effective
resistance is bounded by alpha is
equivalent to saying that Li Susu it's
equivalent to saying that Li is bounded
by alpha times the sum of the all of the
laplacian so so if you have such a
condition basically Marcos movements the
rest of us showed that you can get a
spectral eating tree but here we we have
we have this condition only for set F
on the other hand what we know is that
the set F is KH connected
okay so by the statement that I just
arise there exists some distribution Moo
I'm spanning trees from F
at the probability that I is included
into a tree sample from you is that most
bounded by one over K so so the sort of
statement that we want to prove now is
that if you have such a distribution mu
then the probability that the sum of Li
I&T Bertie is sampled from mu this thing
being bounded by alpha times the whole
laplacian has positive probability there
exists something in the in the support
of distributions that you have which is
thin with respect to the whole graph so
so that's exactly the kind of statement
we need from from the method of
interlacing families so there's the so
if you if you look at them the original
method of interlacing family is
basically and Harvey and over so so
their method is basically you can think
of it as as the equivalent of this
statement went where this mu where this
distribution mu is is basically a
product distribution
so I'll come back to all of these later
but
so so so the point is that we need we
need some statement like this we need
some statement like that for four
distributions mu which are a little bit
crazy they're not they're not choosing
edges independently of each other
they're just using a very actually
strongly correlated distribution and
edges so so for now let me shell that
statement we'll get back to it in the
second part of a talk so so okay so
let's say that such a statement is true
what do we do so so we still want to
want to find something which which makes
sure that some K edge connected subset
of the graph some eh connected subset of
the graph will end up having small
effective resistances right so so the
graph H that we're going to add to so
the the set of edges that we're going to
add we need to make sure that it doesn't
blow up the sizes of the cuts and it's
it generally infeasible to check that
but here is a here's a simple condition
that would guarantee that you wouldn't
blow up the sizes of the cuts what if
you use basically short cuts okay so so
let's say that the graph G that you
started with was the gray edges and it
just that you're adding or the
highlighted edges in orange okay if you
can make sure that the orange edges are
routable and the gray edges so you can
replace each one of them by a
distribution on paths from the original
graph so that no edges used more than
once in total okay so that would make
sure that you're not using more than the
original number of edges in every cut
now now instead of basically instead of
doing instead of using these shortcuts
you can if you don't care about
basically being algorithmically
checkable and what you can do is you can
just you can just write down an
exponentially large convex program and
put the constraints that in every cut
you're not blowing up the size of the
cut okay so so you put down basically
variables for vary your adding the edges
and then the constraints would be
basically that in every cut the the
quadratic form of the laplacian is
bounded by the quadratic form of the
original graphs laplacian and there is
actually no need for you to be working
with laplacian at all you can just add a
PSD matrix to your graph as long as you
make sure that the value on the on these
special vectors on the indicator vectors
offsets doesn't blow up everything still
goes through
so all right so so so so you can
basically write down so you can reduce
the existence of you can check whether
such a such a PSD matrix exists by
basically writing the on a convex work
you just write down the conditions that
you're not blowing up the sizes of the
cut and then you you also write down the
objective which is the effective
resistance of the original graph edges
in such a convex program so so even
though this is an exponential sized
convex program and we can't
algorithmically solve it it's still
useful to write it in this form because
you can use convex programming duality
to to analyze this mathematically and
basically prove that if the graph is
kage connected maybe you can prove the
objective is low rap sub D plus D that
that would be ref G Plus D but they're
not that different so so if you if you
replace basically D prime to be D plus G
then D prime is thin with respect to G
if and only if T is right so you can
measure the effective resistance with
respect to just be that's still fine
oh yeah so all right so if such a if
such a matrix D exists why can we use
that statement over there to prove the
existence of a spectral Ethan tree so
the point is
so take the above statement this
statement what you can do basically is
that you have your original graph
laplacian l1 through LM but you're also
adding this matrix D right so the matrix
D there are many ways of writing this as
a sum of rank one matrices maybe you
maybe pick one so so let's say it's sum
of a 1 up to some a G right so you add
these rank four matrices to your set so
not so now you have a 1 up to 80
now you still let me be the
spanning-tree distribution on on
original edges
right which is going to satisfy the the
fact that the probability of every
element being selected in it is that
most by the bounded by 1 over K so if
the if the desired outcome happens if
there exists basically three such that
the sum of Li is bounded by alpha times
then you are done right because now you
get a aspect to this entry with respect
to your graph plus D but then this means
that for every indicator s for s the
number of edges you have in the cut is
at most power mode by of alpha times the
quadratic form of L of G Plus D while we
did that the cut and this is bounded
again by O of alpha times the number of
edges that you have in the cut
so if the desired outcome happens then
you're done right
but the assumptions if you look at the
assumptions okay so this one is checked
but the other one this one is not
necessarily checked right because we
have we have new things we don't just
have the original graph laplacian we
also have to check this condition for a
is 2 right so we have to check
this thing / or time's up
right
but this is this is a trivial problem to
solve right if you so so this this this
decomposition into rank one matrices var
was arbitrary right in particular I can
replace one of these AIS by K copies of
it scaled by 1 over K right so I can
just make a is as small as I want right
and eventually you were gonna you're
going to make sure that each AI is
bounded by the whole thing the point is
that a eyes are never chosen in the
distribution view so it's really so we
don't really care about them that much
can you explain what you mean by
effective resistant oh oh yeah so it's
just the same quadratic form sorry yeah
so effective resistance of some edge
with respect to D it's just basically
the same the same thing that you would
write for laplacian except here with the
inverse
so the point is that if D is laplacian
of some graph G then this thing is
effective resistance in G
linear in the end recently no it's not
so you're taking the you're taking D and
you're inverting it oh yeah that's
that's a very good point so it's you can
turn it into a semi definite program
what you have to use is basically sure
compliments so there is so so if you
basically form this matrix like this
this matrix is basically positive semi
definite if and only if as long as D is
positive semi definite if and only if
basically be e times D times the thing
is
it is upper bounded by T sorry yeah
so you can make it into a into an SDP
but that's right that's really not that
important for this talk all right
so so now the question is how do we
analyze this this convex program can we
can we make sure that the such a graph
or such a matrix D exists so let me let
me let me give you a toy example first
so so let's say that we don't care about
thinness in every cut let's say that
there is some special family of cuts in
particular degree cuts the cut around
every vertex and we only care about
thinness in these cuts okay so so let's
let's call this the greet entry so so we
want to we have a graph G and we want to
find another graph or a spanning tree
with T such that for degree cuts this
inequality is satisfied okay so the
degree of every vertex is bounded by
alpha times the degree in G so so if we
want to do this we can we can make sure
we only need to make sure that the D
that we add doesn't blow up the degree
cuts
so so let me just say that there has
been a lot of this problem is actually
studied finding trees that are thinning
degree cuts and we know very good bounds
for it but this is just to demonstrate
this framework all of these methods are
more combinator and don't follow this so
is there a graph or or a matrix T that
we can add to our graph which doesn't
blow up the degree cuts but make sure
that the effective resistance is become
small so the answer is that you can
always add an expander to your graph and
make sure that this happens so what's
the point the point is that if you add
an expander to your graph you're not
blowing up so so this is a this is a
constant degree expander so let's say a
3 regular or or K regular expander
so if H is an expander is let say a
regular expander
then G Plus H its degree cards are not
blown up because the degree cut each
degree card of G was at least K so so
this thing basically you know it at s
and s complement is at most twice G of
SNS complement or degree cuts s
but the laplacian of said the Laplace
the point is that the laplacian of of an
expander is a very good approximation to
the laplacian of the complete graph
right and so L of h is spectrally
similar to L of kN right so then it
means that the effective resistance of
every edge with respect to H is bounded
by all 1 over K this you can just prove
for for expanders right so so if you
didn't care about thinness I know you
only cared about degree thinness this is
the this is how you would do it
now let's go back to the original
problem can we always found find well
conditioners for for all cuts right so
so this is the same convex program as
before you can just try to analyze it
the problem is that even if you use
convex duality and try to to make sure
that the try to basically prove that
this is bounded you would you would find
actually a counter example so so there
are actually KH connected graphs for
which this is basic the answer to this
convex program is basically constant you
can't bring down the effective
resistances so what you can do is you
can again relax and instead of trying to
make sure that the effective resistance
of every original edge is small you can
make sure you can basically find a K
edge connected subgraph of the original
graph
so so so the problem is that it's hard
to make sure the effective resistance of
every edge comes down you can just again
relax that and make sure that the
effective resistance of a subset comes
down and that subset is big enough to
support their cage connected graph so so
to make so yeah so to make sure that
that that you find such a cage to
connect a subgraph one strategy is to
make sure that the average effective
resistance in every cut is small that
would imply cage connectivity of low
effective resistance edges that's still
bad news but there are some strategies
that you can you can deal you can use to
to deal with this I'm running a little
bit low on time let me let me just
so the point is so the end point is that
you can find you can find a hierarchy
called the composition of your graph and
what you can make sure is that in this
hierarchy called the composition in
every degree cut of the hierarchy there
exists at least Omega of K edges whose
effective resistance has been lowered so
now in each level of the hierarchy you
have a KH connected subgraph and because
you have a hierarchical decomposition
the entire thing becomes gauge correct
so so let me just skip this because I
wanted to switch to to the interlacing
families part so so low so now let's
switch gears entirely and work on this
statement
[Music]
so this is again the kind of statement
that we want to prove that if you have a
bunch of rank fun
PST matrices and you have a crazy
distribution on subsets of them then the
probability that for something or there
exists something in the support of your
distribution which is thin so so so the
method of proving such statements is is
pretty much the same as what you would
do with the original interlacing
families proofs so let me give you an
overview of this so so if you remember
we had this tree in the beginning
so we had a tree in the beginning whose
Leafs were specific polynomials so these
formulas are associated to spanning
trees in our distribution so there is P
of P 1 P of T 2
and you have this crazy distribution
that takes average of these things and
at the bar at the top you have
expectation of T selected according to
new of PT of Z
so this is the same tree we had in the
beginning so so the way you you built
the you build this tree is basically by
by conditioning on whether or not each
edges inside the tree or not okay so
this is so the the nodes on here are
basically T given that let's say one
wasn't he
this one is that PT of Z and that one
was not easy
so this is this is for edge one and you
go down the tree again for 4h 2 and so
on so so so the branching in the tree
basically corresponds to your decisions
about whether or not you should include
an edge inside the inside the tree that
you're selecting or not on the bottom
and the leaves you have actual spanning
trees and what you need to do is you
should put down power meals here that
course whose roots correspond to the
thinness of the tree ok so it's easy to
put down these polynomials so what you
can do is you can form a determinant
alcohol
so so the point is if you if you choose
your paw meals to be like this then max
root of PTZ is bounded by alpha if and
only if he is alpha aspect related
so okay so so the original strategy of
Marcus Valencia Rostova was also similar
to this you you basically condition one
by one on whether or not elements are
inside your set s or not and then what
you what you have to prove is that first
of all this is a this is an interlacing
family of polynomials so meaning that
all of the intermediate nodes are real
rooted and convex combinations of
siblings are also real rooted so then
that would tell you that if you have a
bound on the roots of the polynomial on
the top you can find something in the
leaves whose roots are bounded and then
the the second more important thing is
to to prove that the the roots at the
top are are bounded so so again similar
to the original interlacing families
method both of these statements are
proved by writing the the polynomial at
the top in a different way
so what you want to do is to prove that
this thing is real do that where T is
chosen according to this crazy
distribution muon spanning trees right
and so here is the here is the punchline
that if this is the polynomial G of Z
you can write G of Z in this form
times
so let me let me parse that for you so
so you have a poem you'll associated to
your matrices le right in fact each of
those PT power meals you can write it as
so let's call this so this is a
polynomial that encodes all of those
specific power meals and the leaves as
its specializations so so so basically
PT of Z is just H of Y all one's vector
minus or Z times they all one's vector
minus the indicator of a spanning tree
this polynomial is encoding your
distribution mu so so so it's basically
this is the sum over all spanning trees
in your so it's so it's the expectation
of T chosen according to mu of Z to the
T as the expectation of the product of
so so for each tree you can associate a
monomial which is the product of the the
variables associated to the edges inside
the tree and if you take this
expectation over the distribution under
spanning trees you get a polynomial
whose coefficients are basically and
capturing the the probabilities of the
the probability is given by Mew to the
specific spanning trees right now the
point is that this is a this is a
determinant of palm yo so it is real
stable this also turns out to be a palm
capturing a strongly Rayleigh
distribution so it's the generating
polynomial of a stronger distribution so
it is also real stable so once you take
the product of two real stable
distributions you get a real stable the
product of two real stable panels you
still get a real stable Palmilla and
these are operators that preserve real
stability
so so the reason these operators
preserved real stability is that is that
the basically the whole meal y minus 1
minus y squared is reloaded so it's a so
it's a known fact that if you have a
polynomial which is reloaded and he
replace its variables by partial
derivative operators it is a real
stability preserver also because the
factor 1 by in this shirt you can also
factor it and then I mean it's basically
saying the same thing yes you can also
factor this into 1 minus partial times 1
plus partial and each of those would be
would be real stability preserve okay so
so so the end result is going to oh I
forgot so at the end you also have to
plug in basically ze equal Z so you have
to symmetrize all the variables so you
start from two real stable power wheels
you take their product you apply a bunch
of real stability preservers the end
result is going to be real stable and
then you make it univariate you plug in
the same variable for all so the end
result is going to be G of Z squared
which is real stable but if G of Z
squared is real stable then G of Z is
also real estate so so yeah so that's
the that's the proof that the know that
the top is real stable but then for for
other nodes what you can do is you can
just condition your distribution on the
edge one being inside where the edge one
being outside and so on the point is
that conditional versions of if you
condition a stronger I distribution you
remain strongly so everything still goes
through and all of the intermediate
nodes also become real estate
[Music]
so so the other thing that you have to
show to prove that the family interlaces
is that you have to prove the convex
combination of siblings is also real
rooted okay so that proves that
basically siblings or sibling
polynomials industry have interlacing
roots okay but if you take it so so
there is one particular convex
combination of siblings which we know is
really that right so so there is a
convex combination of these two that
gives you exactly this right but we have
to prove that for every convex
combination you get this right but but
if you choose a different convex
combination it's as if you're you're
basically playing with the weights of
the edge on the weight of the the weight
of edge one in your random Stanek
spanning tree distribution so if you if
you play with that weight you can get
any convex combination of these two
problems okay and for all choices of
weights you the spanning tree
distribution the evaded spanning tree
distribution is strong arriving so that
proves that the family interlaces and
then the way that you prove the the the
pow/mia at the top has bounded roots is
again by by methods very much similar to
marcus effeminacy Rostova so
I go a little bit over so yeah so let me
just give you the high level so the high
level is that you still have to
introduce barrier functions barrier
functions are basically derivatives of
the log of your polynomial so you you
prove that the derivative of the log of
the poem you'll hear initially is
bounded and the derivative of the log of
the product of these two polynomials is
just the sum of the derivatives of each
one the derivatives of log of this one
being bounded corresponds to the
probability the marginals of the
distribution mu being bounded and the
derivatives a blog of this one being
bound that corresponds to the other
condition we needed this one so so
initially the derivatives of the log of
this polynomial are bounded and then you
can prove that
after you apply each of these operators
you can basically shift your palm you
also that the derivatives of the log are
bounded by what they were furious so so
that's just a high-level picture of
what's happening and yeah so that's
that's how you prove such a statement
let me let me just conclude so what I so
what I give you what I gave you was
basically a sketch of this fact that
every K edge connected graph has a has a
thin tree which is poly log log n times
worse than what you would expect or what
the conjecture is see are there are
obvious questions one of them is can we
build these thin trees that we know
exist efficiently using an algorithm and
this very much goes back to the question
of whether or not you can make the
method of interlacing families
algorithmic so so the obvious the the
other obvious question is whether or not
we can remove the dependency on n that
would that would have a lot of
implications even for for the asymmetric
Traveling Salesman problem
so I gave you this toy example about
degree cuts right and what about other
families of cuts if you if you care
about thinness with respect to some
subset of the cuts for what families can
you get a tight well conditioner and
then finally so so this this method of
interlacing families was originally
invented for real rooted polynomials
right what if instead of a real stable
power mill here you have something which
is not real stable but in the same
vicinity right so so can you can you
basically extend this method to other
distributions mu in particular can you
can you prove an analogous statement
when mu is a lock concave distribution
I just want to improve the the
conclusion of the statement that that
this probability is oh sorry this
shouldn't be equality that this
probability is positive as long as your
distribution mu has a lock concave form
yo and as long as these two conditions
are satisfied
so that would that would probably
require you to go or to change something
in the interlacing families method and I
think that would be an interesting
exercise yeah thanks you sure there are
these bad news yeah so so to basically
deal with that bad news we had to we had
to make compromises and I didn't go over
what those compromises are at all but
there are several phases very log well
again shows up and and yeah there are
examples where are the convex program
used at the end gives you log log n so
can't possibly good it dialysis is tight
basically I mean it depends on what end
goal is because if your end goal is to
bring down the effective resistance of
every edge down then it wouldn't even
work for log log n right if you make the
compromises on which subset of the edges
you you want to bring down then yeah
yeah so so the statement that could be
true is that there exists a subset of
the edges which is kage connected and
you can bring the effective resistance
of all of them down to only a constant
yes
well thank you again Peter
[Applause]